REQUIREMENT?
NO, DON'T WORRY, WE SOUGHT
BEFORE THEY TOOK IT DOWN AND
HERE'S THE OTHER REQUIREMENT.
BE WILLING TO USE DEADLY FORCE
IF NECESSARY.
JOINING ME NOW IS KENTUCKY
CONGRESSMAN THOMAS MASSIE OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
NARRATIVE IS HORRIBLE AND
COMPLETELY BACKFIRED ON THEM
THIS WEEK BUT I GET THE SENSE
THAT THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
WHAT WE WILL SEE WITH THIS
AGENCY BEING TURNED AGAINST THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> NOT JUST THIS AGENCY, WHAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE MAY NOT REALIZE IS
LAST WEEK, THE DEMOCRATS THROUGH
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE PASSED A
BAN ON THE AR-15.
THEY CALL IT A WEAPON OF WAR,
BUT THEY MADE SURE THEY ARE BAN
EXEMPTED EVERY FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT INCLUDING THE IRS,
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, AND
THE USDA.
YOU'VE GOT TO PUT THAT INTO
CONTEXT THAT THIS WEEK TOMORROW
WE ARE GOING TO BE VOTING TO ADD
87,000 IRS AGENTS TO THE ROLE.
THEN TAKEN WITH THE WEBSITES AND
LIKE YOU SHOWED, LOOK, THEY GOT
CAUGHT.
THEY HAD THIS ON THE WEBSITE AND
I LOOKED AT THE INTERNET
ARCHIVES.
THEY PUT IT UP SINCE BIDEN
BECAME PRESIDENT THAT YOU MUST
BE WILLING TO DO DEADLY FORCE.
THEY TOOK IT DOWN YESTERDAY
BECAUSE THEY GOT CAUGHT
RECRUITING THAT WAY.
BY THE WAY, I TALKED TO PEOPLE
WHO SPENT THEIR LIFE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THEY SAID
THIS IS THE LAST THING YOU WOULD
PUT IN A JOB POSTING.
IF YOU GET THE WRONG KIND OF
PEOPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO KILL PEOPLE, JOIN
US!
>> Laura: THE BORDER PATROL
CAN'T EVEN USE DEADLY FORCE
PRETTY MUCH RIGHT?
BORDER PATROL, NO, BUT THE IRS,
YES, THAT'S A TWISTED WORLD
WHERE LIVING IN.
THE NEW ATF DIRECTOR SAT DOWN
WITH CNN TODAY AND WATCH THIS.
>> HE SAT DOWN TO DISCUSS THE
LITANY OF THREATS THAT AGENTS
ARE TRYING TO COUNTER FROM
COAST-TO-COAST INCLUDING A RISE
IN VIOLENT DOMESTIC EXTREMISM.
>> THE FIRST THING YOU NEED TO
DO IS TO BE HONEST ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
I WILL TELL YOU IT'S GOTTEN MORE
BOLD, MORE BRAZEN, MORE VIOLENT.
>> Laura: YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT?
WE HAVE APPARENTLY MASSIVE
DOMESTIC TERRORISM PROBLEMS AND
THEY HAPPEN TO BE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, CONGRESSMAN.
>> WE ASKED THE DOJ ABOUT THIS
AND THE DHS ACTUALLY PUT OUT A
BULLETIN THAT SAID IF YOU DO
CERTAIN THINGS LIKE THE VACCINE
YOU MIGHT BE A VIOLENT DOMESTIC
TERRORIST ARE YOU KNOW, IT'S
CRAZY.
MAYBE YOU GROW YOUR OWN FOOD AND
YOU'LL BE LABELED AS SUCH.
IT'S CRAZY WHAT CAN PUT YOU ON
THE LIST AND I THINK IT'S
DANGEROUS.
>> Laura: TIME TO DEFUND THE
AGENCIES TARGETING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THAT'S